>>> A FEDERAL JUE HAS SENTENCE
A JANUARY 6 RIOTER TO SEVEN
YEARS IN PRISON WHICH IS THE
LONGEST SENTENCE SO FAR FOR
PARTICIPANTS IN THE CAPITOL
INSURRECTION.
SENTENCING FOR GUY REFFITT COMES
NEARLY 20 MONTHS AFTER HE
BROUGHT A GUN TO THE CAPITOL AND
THREATENED HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI.
BACK IN MARCH, A D.C. JURY
CONVICTED RED REFFITT OF FIVE
FELONIES.
HERE'S HOW REFFITT'S DAUGHTERS
REACTED.
>> TO MARK MY DAD AS A HORRIBLE
PERSON, TO HAVE A SENTENCE LIKE
WHERE SOMEBODY IS MAYBE ABLE TO
GET ELECTED AGAIN DOESN'T SEEM
RIGHT TO ME.
>> TRUMP DESERVES LIFE IN PRISON
IF MY FATHER IS IN PRISON FOR
THIS LONG.
>> JOINING US NOW IS GUY
REFFITT'S SON, JACKSON REFFITT.
JACKSON WARNED THE FBI BEFORE
AND AFTER THE INSURRECTION.
JACKSON, THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US THIS MORNING.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
HOW ARE YOU REACTING TO THIS
SENTENCE?
>> I MEAN, I'M NOT HAPPY AT ALL.
I HAVEN'T BEEN HAPPY TO THIS
WHOLE SITUATION.
NO ONE IN MY FAMILY HAS EITHER,
BUT TO SAY I'M SURPRISED WOULD
BE A LIE.
I MEAN, EVERYTHING MY DAD DID,
HE'S HIS OWN PERSON.
AND HIS ACTION HAS CONSEQUENCES.
BUT I'M NOT HAPPY AT ALL.
>> DO YOU THINK HE DESERVES THIS
LENGTH OF SENTENCE?
>> I MEAN, ABSOLUTELY.
HE DESERVES SOME TIME.
WHETHER TO -- FOR ANYTHING, TO
REHABILITATE, FOR HIS MENTAL
HEALTH.
HE DESERVES A LOT OF SAFETY
NETS.
BUT, YES, HE DOES.
>> DO YOU HAVE WORRIES ABOUT HIM
BEING IN PRISON THAT LONG.
YOU MENTIONED HIS MENTAL HEALTH.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, THE PRISON SYSTEM IN
THIS COUNTRY HAVE BEEN PRETTY
HARSH FOR A LOT OF REASONS.
AND TO BLAME MY DAD'S
DETERIORATING MENTAL HEALTH FOR
A FRIDAY BAD EFFECT ON HIM, I'M
NOT GOING TO BE SURPRISED.
BUT, I MEAN, THAT'S WHY I
MENTIONED IT IN MY LETTER.
>> DO YOU KNOW, OR HAVE YOU
THROUGHOUT ANY OF THIS PROCESS
HAD ANY SECOND THOUGHTS ABOUT
TURNING HIM IN?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
BUT IT STILL BEARS THE GUILT
THAT HE IS HIS OWN PERSON AND HE
HAS MADE HIS OWN CHOICES.
BUT HE'S ALSO BEEN PRETTY MUCH
MANIPULATED INTO MAKING THOSE
CHOICES.
AND IT PAINS ME THAT HE'S STILL
RESPONSIBLE FOR HIS ACTIONS.
>> JACKSON, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THIS HAS DONE TO YOUR
FAMILY.
THIS IS YOUR MOM SPEAKING
YESTERDAY.
I WANT TO LISTEN TO THIS.
>> NO MATTER IF YOU'RE A LIBERAL
IF YOU'RE AN INDEPENDENT, IF
YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN, THIS IS NOT
OKAY.
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS.
IT'S POLITICAL PERSECUTION.
WE ARE PATRIOTS.
ASHLI BABBITT WAS A PATRIOT.
MY HUSBAND IS A PATRIOT.
ROSE ANNE BOYLAN WAS A PATRIOT.
ALL I CAN SAY, Y'ALL CAN GO TO
HELL AND I'M GOING BACK TO
TEXAS.
>> WHAT IS YOUR RELATIONSHIP
LIKE WITH YOUR MOM, WITH YOUR
SISTERS?
>> IT'S BEEN REALLY HARD OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
THEY'VE REALLY POLARIZING
DIFFERENCES IN HOW WE VIEW OUR
FATHER AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
WHAT MY FATHER WAS IN.
BUT -- AND IT FEELS LIKE WE'RE
EACH PULLING ON EACH STRING, ONE
WAY.
BUT I DON'T VIEW THIS AS A
POLITICAL MATTER.
THIS IS MORE OF WHAT IS MORALLY
CORRECT AND HOW TO GO ABOUT IT.
AND WHAT MY FATHER WAS
MANIPULATED INTO DOING AND WHAT
HE LED TO THINK WAS THE BEST AND
ONLY WAY TO DO IT, HE DECIDED,
AS AN ADULT, TO MAKE THOSE
CHOICES.
AND WHETHER MY FAMILY VIEWS IT
ANY DIFFERENTLY, IT DOESN'T HAVE
AN EFFECT ON THE OUTCOME.
>> WHEN YOU HEARD -- YOU HEARD
WHAT YOUR MOM SAID THERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT SHE
SAID?
>> THIS -- I MEAN,
REALISTICALLY, THIS DOESN'T HAVE
A MATTER OF POLITICAL OPINION.
WHAT MY FATHER DID IS FAR FROM
POLITICS.
THIS IS COMPLETELY OFF THE RAILS
VIOLENCE.
WHETHER IT HAD A POLITICAL
MOTIVE AT THIS POINT DOESN'T
MATTER.
IT'S MORE ABOUT WHAT HE DOES AND
WHO HE DID IT FOR.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE, YOU KNOW, YOUR
SISTER PEYTON, LISTENING TO HER,
SHE FEELS KIND OF CAUGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS.
SHE'S THERE AT THE COURTHOUSE.
SHE LOVES YOU.
SHE MADE THAT CLEAR YESTERDAY.
SHE THINKS THAT YOUR DAD, IF
HE'S GETTING THIS TIME THAT
TRUMP SHOULD BE GETTING SOME
TIME.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN SHE SAID THAT, I WAS
FLAFLAB
FLABBE
FLABBERGHASTED.
NOT ONLY WAS I IMPRESSED WITH
HER, SHE'S SO RIGHT.
MY DAD WAS USED AS A PUPPET, AND
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES HAVE BEEN.
WHETHER YOU AGREE WITH THAT,
IT'S A FACT AT THIS POINT.
IT IS DISGUSTING TO SEE THAT
SOMEONE WITH PRACTICALLY MONEY
AND SOCIAL POWER CAN JUST GET
AWAY WITH MANIPULATING THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE JUST FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
AND HAVE NO OUTCOME.
>> WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS SENTENCE
WHICH IS THE LONGEST ONE WE'VE
SEEN SO FAR FOR A JANUARY 6th
PARTICIPANT, PART OF THE REASON
WAS THAT YOUR FATHER CARRIED A
WEAPON.
HE DID NOT ENTER THE CAPITOL,
BUT HE ALSO DECIDED THAT HE WAS
GOING TO TRIAL INSTEAD OF
ACCEPTING A PLEA.
AND THAT OBVIOUSLY IS SOMETHING
THAT WOULD HAVE POTENTIALLY
GOTTEN HIM A LONGER SENTENCE,
MORE TIME IN JAIL.
IT SEEMED IN COURT THAT HE
REGRETTED THAT A BIT.
BUT WHY DO YOU THINK THAT HE
WANTED TO DO THAT INITIALLY?
WHY DO YOU THINK HE WANTED TO BE
AN EXAMPLE?
>> I CAN'T THINK -- I CAN'T
THINK OF ANYTHING OTHER THAN MY
OWN EXPERIENCE WITH MY FATHER,
KNOWING HE'S A NARCISSIST, AND
HE HAS A RATHER LARGE EGO.
AND IT WAS HORRIBLE TO SEE HIM
MAKE THAT DECISION, KNOWING THAT
HE COULD HAVE GOTTEN A MUCH
EASIER, AND I FEARED THE MOMENT
THAT HE WAS OFFERED THAT AND HE
DENIED IT, THAT HE WOULD DENY IT
AND TRY TO FIGHT IT IN COURT.
AND I KNEW THAT IT WASN'T GOING
TO END UP OTHER THAN ANYTHING
THAT IT IS RIGHT NOW.
>> HAVE YOU TALKED TO HIM SINCE
HE WAS ARRESTED?
AND HAVE YOU TALKED TO HIM SINCE
HE WAS SENTENCED?
>> BRIEFLY.
I HAD A REALLY WEIRD PHONE CALL
WITH HIM THAT WAS REALLY
AWKWARD.
BUT, YEAH, YEAH, I TALKED TO HIM
ONCE, AND WE DID NOT TALK ABOUT
ANYTHING OTHER THAN LIKE
MAGMAGIC
GATHERING THEY HAVE GUARDS IN
PRISON.
>> IT WAS JUST HELLO AND TALKING
ABOUT MAGIC THE GATHERING AND
THAT WAS IT?
>> YEAH, IT WAS, IT WAS REALLY
WEIRD.
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO TALK TO HIM
AGAIN.
>> YOU WOULD LOVE TO SPEAK TO
HIM AGAIN.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO HIM,
JACKSON?
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHETHER --
I DON'T WANT TO ENGAGE WITH SUCH
DEEP EMOTION WITH HIM RIGHT NOW.
IT STILL IS TAKING A LOT OF
TIME.
I STILL DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO
PROCESS RIGHT NOW, IN TERMS OF
WHAT I'M ACTUALLY FEELING.
BUT I WOULD JUST TALK ABOUT THE
MOST POINTLESS STUFF, JUST TO
GO -- HAVE A ONE-ON-ONE WITH
HIM, AT LEAST.
A COUPLE MORE TIMES BEFORE HE
GETS OUT.
>> BECAUSE HE'S YOUR DAD?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE'S STILL MY FATHER.
THAT DOESN'T JUSTIFY ANYTHING
THAT HE'S DONE.
BUT IT'S STILL -- I STILL HAVE
THAT ATTACHMENT TO HIM.
>> JACKSON, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TAKING THE TIME WITH US THIS
MORNING.
WE APPRECIATE IT.